you weren't given that platform the
platform of this late-night show because
of your political views you were given
the platform in order to create comedy
your job is to create comedy and in
these scenarios it's more important ever
your job is more important than on days
where it's easy to do Jimmy Kimmel was
number one trend on YouTube social media
today I'm starting to realize the
trending list is not so much about
what's trending but what YouTube wants
to be trending before I move on because
we'll talk about Jimmy Kimmel's
grandstanding and of course that's just
a litany of factual airs question of the
day are you still able to watch
late-night usually I'm able to separate
the art from the artists we've talked
about that but at what point is it too
much at what point does a propagandizing
become so blatant that you just have to
tune out it's it's become really hard
and I was it that was the biggest gun
fan huge Conan fan I can't watch it
Jimmy Kimmel went up and of course is
this is the rule rather than the
exception crying talking about the Las
Vegas shooting and listen this is the
first off let's address a tragedy
absolutely I think that every side both
the left and the right care about lives
lost we just have different solutions
and of course I believe that one side is
more informed on what are actually
pragmatic solutions versus the other but
let's walk through Jimmy Kimmel's recent
number one trending diatribe course we
pray for the victims and for their
families and friends and we wonder why
even though there's probably no way to
ever know why a human being would do
something like this to other human
beings River at a concert this is
important because it sets it up it's a
really simple answer why it's called
evil yeah it's something the Left
refuses to acknowledge exist because at
that point then I was in the situational
ethics and they no longer function you
need to have a base of some kind of
principle listen it's horrible it
doesn't mean that you have to comprehend
evil on an empathetic let it is horrible
it should be absolutely disgusting but
it's not a complex question why would
someone do it evil what led them to
their evil will then we'll get it and
what allowed them to commit that act of
evil and what's the best way to curb it
moving forward that's the discussion we
should be having let's move on there are
a lot of things we can do about it well
we don't which is interesting because
when someone with a beard attacks us we
phones we invoke travel bans we build
walls we take every possible precaution
the metric doesn't happen again
currently an American buys a gun and
kills other Americans then there's
nothing we can do about that and Second
Amendment I guess are yes more fathers
wanted us to have a que 47 is the
argument I assume now I don't know if
Chuck Schumer is writing this one for
him as well as what happened with the
health care issue but um yeah Second
Amendment founding fathers just because
you act as though it's absurd doesn't
make an absurd our founders wanted to
have so just a few things we'll list off
here that he was wrong about ak-47s
that's an easy one just go and watch one
of our previous videos as a Second
Amendment for muskets only not only if
you understand the wording in the
history of the Second Amendment did it
of course apply to modern-day weaponry
but even back then there was a Puckle
gun the jiren donee air rifle
there was actually a letter written of
marque and reprisal to a private ship
they were allowing them to personally
have cannons it was written of course
you're gonna have cannons you never
protect your ship do it the idea that it
was only relegated to muskets is so
quickly and thoroughly debunked that
we've done it we won't waste a ton of
time when I hear then he goes on to say
hope of a person with the beard let's be
honest about what he's talking about
here he means a brown person what's a
beard this is the whole identity
politics as though if it's Muslim we
care but if it's a white person we don't
care okay let's let's go with that I'll
admit to a certain degree of that why
because of a consistent pattern of
behavior based on ideology and outlier
is just that an outlier but if you can
actually look at a correlation between
people who follow a very specific a
political prescription as well as a
religion as we do with Islam guess what
it should be relevant because that comes
to the discussion can we do something
about it so let's go to why someone
might think someone with a beard could
be a little bit different than just the
random white guy who's out of his mind
or white supremacist who the left loves
to scream about okay this is one thing
that's important because I saw this at
Vox I call this the 9/11 fallacy where
the quote is since 9/11 a hundred and
six people have been killed by far-right
violent extremists in the u.s. 119 have
been killed by Islamists so it seems
comparable now if you include one day
earlier nine
that puts a number over 3,100 some would
say significant there might say now I
get you can say what we shouldn't
include it we should include it but
again you're starting after an act of
global terrorism committed by the guys
with the beards glow and this is just a
united state statistic so you see this
at Vox you see people like Jimmy Kimmel
parody Islamic attacks globally that's
the important number they account for
more than 74 percent of all deaths from
terrorism Isis Boko Haram Taliban al
Qaeda okay there's nothing there's
there's no surprise there so if someone
who's brown does it with a beard
shouting out Allahu Akbar doesn't matter
more no it means that we have more of a
semblance of a motive and if we see
other people shouting Allahu Akbar we
have to recognize a pattern of behavior
now he doesn't he goes on this I love
this he says we're because of this we go
we invoke travel bans we build the walls
just skims over it well okay you say
there's nothing we get does that help
stop terror attacks securing borders and
profiling we can mock it but does it
work they work everywhere they've been
implemented from Israel to Hungary
Israel experienced a 90 percent drop in
terror attacks after building a fence in
the West Bank
Hungary cut its influx of migrants from
several thousand a day to less than 40
just by rent for a couple offenses and
the important thing to remember here
again Islam is an ideology why would the
beard why would the garb matter because
it's a representation of what he
believes a belief that prescribes him to
kill other people contrast that was his
shooter no no affiliations motivations
yet or history of crime yet would
securing the border stop that no we're
putting up a wall stop this guy probably
not with anything short of a complete
and total gun ban stopped this guy no
and by the way that wouldn't work either
No
so what does Jimmy Kimmel hauls are
cheap to rent yes what did you make you
might want to say do you want to be
Minority Report or you arrest people for
crimes they have yet to commit since the
beginning of time there been bad people
committing bad things because evil lives
amongst us it brings us back to that
point if you acknowledge evil then you
can be honest about the conversation
that we're having next clip every one of
these shootings of murder used automatic
or semi-automatic rifles everyone
weapons you know use them for
self-defense
incorrectly designed to kill large
numbers of people in the shortest
possible amount of time this
I reportedly had ten of them in his room
apparently legally at least some of them
were there illegally why is that allowed
okay couple things you know those who
probably have ten in their room people
in your security detail Jimmy Kimmel
yeah bet you they probably have a lot of
scary black rifles that you don't know
about but because they do you get to
sleep at night and be escorted to and
from your Hollywood studios so here he
just says some things that are factually
completely incorrect he says all of
these mass shootings doesn't even say a
lot of them he says all of these
nationalists would use again the first
lesson Jimmy Kimmel don't use those
don't use absolutes when you have no
idea as to what the hell you're talking
about okay when you're dumb and horrible
always everyone try and cover your
tracks a little bit not everyone out
there if it's an argument for truth you
don't you do it but when you're a dumb
baggage like Jimmy Kimmel it pays to not
take chances let's assume he weren't an
absolute simpleton and as soon as he
said far more mass shootings not even
all we'll give him some more leeway no
more mass shootings committed by the
assault rifle it's not even true if we
take mass shootings meaning four or more
take any shootings the FBI data show
that in 2012 only three hundred and
twenty something of over eleven thousand
people shot in the u.s. were killed by
rifles of any kind they're committed by
handguns far more another thing he does
word trick or you've talked about this
he conflate two automatic with
semi-automatic it's like it's like
comparing a hamburger and lasagna
they're both food it's not the same
thing
nearly all guns today sold for those who
don't know and again they're banking on
you not knowing Jimmy Kimmel is banking
on you being as moronic as him pistols
semi-automatic most guns that are sold
today semi-automatic most there in the
years defensively semi automatics but as
far as in practice a revolver acts like
a semi-automatic on a technical level
there isn't a semi-automatic re
chambering of around put one trigger
pull one round one bullet that's what
semi-automatic means fully automatic is
heavily regulated and basically it's not
available to the average centers and he
goes he says there's no defensive
purpose for this guns incorrect there
are no defensive uses they're actually
used to say far more lives than they
ever take that's the bit that's the
story people don't talk about we know
according from the United States Census
Bureau that at least a hundred thousand
to three million somewhere even the left
has to acknowledge it's somewhere close
to two million cases each year of
firearms used
now why is there such a discrepancy
because it's hard to measure how many
lives are saved by someone brandishing a
gun and never actually using it on fire
yet guns are used to save more lives and
yes that means the scary black rifles
they're used defensively far more than
offensively so again if you go oh what's
a semi-automatic and automatic you don't
know and hey there's no defensive use
for these firearms I guess that may you
could actually start to believe some of
the bullcrap coming out from Jimmy
Kimmel luckily there's more that we can
debug today this morning she said it was
not the time for political debate and I
don't know we have 59 innocent people
dead it wasn't their time either so I
think now is the time for political
debate well I'm glad you think so Jimmy
it's not like it would be time for your
comedic monologue this is the arrogance
of the Hollywood left City he presumes
to speak on behalf of everyone else okay
in this context let's take this these 59
people died in Las Vegas at a country
concert how much do you want to bet but
at least a plurality of them would hate
Jimmy Kimmel speaking for them it's you
know in February he also signed a bill
that made it easier for people with
severe mental illness to buy guns
legally that's actually not true okay
and this is one thing the Billy's
talking about it was actually reversing
an Obama administration rule that
actually took second amendment basic
rights away from seniors who were
declared incompetent to manage their
pension or disability payments even the
ACLU came out against this Obama rule
okay so let's just talk that piece of
legislation we need it we need to deal
right here with some pragmatics and the
philosophical when it comes to the
Second Amendment so no he's wrong he's
incorrect he's not explaining what that
is go to the source that we just listed
hopefully you can learn more about that
bill but again people talk of this
conversation well if you're if you're
the mentally ill okay this is important
we needed to find what is mentally ill
now keep in mind if you look at the four
dissenting Supreme Court justices on the
hello versus DC case they don't believe
you have the right to own a firearm at
all again this is important the legal
argument is not oh it's only four
muskets the legal argument isn't well it
should only be revolvers or pump shotgun
the only legal argument made at the
Supreme Court is you have no right
period to private firearm ownership
period ever period that's the argument
that they make so you need to understand
into that to then okay scale it back
when they say mental health what do they
mean well they want everybody to be
banned from having any kinds of firearms
do you really want the federal
government in control as to your right
to self-preservation your god-given
right to self-preservation because
you've taken a xanax you think it's a
slippery slope it's actually been
proposed it's so crazy right now there
are loopholes in the law that let people
avoid another party they bind on online
or at a gun show no no okay go and see
we did a video on this gun show loophole
a hidden-camera video it is it is
completely false first online loophole
it doesn't even exist now the gun show
loophole comes to this idea of private
transactions that usually occur between
family members okay
Obama was the one who popularized this
myth and he used that term we actually
went to the gun show in Indiana remember
not kids you heard the famous when they
were that he referred to and no one
would give us a gun through the gun show
loophole you can go watch the video
maybe just really done and picked a
really bad exists it's still a thing
bunk so many times saying because people
like Jimmy Kimmel who aren't doing their
job of writing comedy don't know the
difference between an automatic or
semi-automatic rifle and people are
getting their information from him hey
Jimmy what's the revolver why do you
pull something and something comes out
of there I want you determining our gun
control legislation several one trend on
YouTube it's a myth that was popularized
by Obama and it was such a it was such
an unbelievably blatant lie even
Washington Post gave it two Pinocchio's
which apparently is a valid system of
rape a valid newspaper next clip by the
way the House of Representatives will be
voting on a piece of legislation this
week it's a bill to legalize the sale of
of silencers for guns this is what
they're working on we have a major
problem with gun violence in this
country and I guess they don't care and
if I'm wrong on that fine do something
about it cuz I'm sick of it
you think some films of course again
this just goes to show you this is one
of those arguments anyone you know out
there who's pro-gun control buy them a
gun
that's a hashtag gift a gun buy them at
done they'll never be pro-gun control
again they'll never be gun control
proponents again I should say they'll
never be anti-gun activist again because
right they'll go through the background
check so understand what's necessary
classes even better sign them up for
concealed carry course ok this is one of
those arguments that is very simple to
describe it is an argument between
completely uninformed people who know
nothing about firearms and firearm
owners that's it you don't get the
firearm owners who side with someone
like Jimmy Kimmel so uh he goes
suppressors by the way this is important
he talks about the spread they don't
make it whisper quiet and it's actually
common practice in Europe again strict
gun control but if you're a hunter it's
considered rude to not use it yeah for
noise pollution for hunters nearby
silencers are designed to protect
hearing for hunters and shooters right
let's put this again into the pragmatic
let's talk about the Vegas shooting okay
you're trying to figure out where the
gunshots are coming from so if there's
no silencer let me give you a difference
it would be pop-pop head down oh I think
he's up there okay a silencer would be
head down pop-pop oh he's there it would
be that much of a difference hitman
Hillary been watching too many
double-oh-seven films what I'm talking
about tonight isn't about gun control
it's about common sense commentary about
gun control ever come from allowing
person to have weapons that can take
down 527 Americans at a concert you know
in June of last year the NRA fought to
make sure people on the no-fly list can
buy guns they aren't using it on the
plane they're allowed to own a very
dangerous gun who thinks that makes
sense are you noticing a theme here yeah
again it's not a fundamental human right
to get on a plane it's not a fundamental
human right to get your your Southwest
Airlines peanuts by the way I love the
biscuits in Delta Dara they are
delicious I wish I could buy this
restore me when you send me the message
but you noticing a point here there's no
flowers you can't even get in a plane
but you can buy okay again completely
uninformed
verses all it takes is one quick search
so you know what the no-fly list is it's
not a terror watchlist it's not an
official list you don't have to have
committed any crime be involved with any
terrorist organization or even have
looked at somebody the wrong way you can
be put in enough light
how do we know because thousands of
people have been put on the no-fly list
with no cause due process or any means
of retribution even slate said the US
government is putting Americans on its
no-fly list
on a hunch you can look up the names you
can look up a list of names just to
people I think was Senator Ted Kennedy
and Kennedy nihilist so this is again
they're hoping you don't run a quick
search on the no-fly list Jimmy Kimmel
who decided that he was going to go up
and by the way cry from 0 to 60 it
wasn't like it came over him he cried
immediately I wonder was he crying in
the makeup chair was he crying in the
groom he walked out crying he's hoping
that you just don't run a rudimentary
search on the no-fly list I would
encourage you to please do so in the
comment below if you learned something
next clip maybe I'm nuts but I would
like to think we could put politics
aside agree that no American citizen
needs an m16 or ten of them nobody has
one and 16 there select-fire auto rifles
not sold for civilian use what's your
point last clip I can't do this much you
know I want this to be a comedy show I
hate talking about stuff like this no
you don't I just want to you know laugh
about things every night but they don't
it seems to becoming increasingly
difficult lately all right this is gonna
sound callous
it just means you suck at your job if
it's increasingly difficult you're a
comedian your job is to be a comedian we
did it we laughed last night
why can't you Jimmy Kimmel matter of
fact the only time Jimmy Kimmel is ever
trending the only time is when his
political grandstanding his comedy can't
even generate the play of not gay Jerrod
dressed in drag you're welcome you know
it's it's it's difficult to do comedy
well okay and what are their jobs do you
get to do that this is this is what
comes back for the late-night show okay
if you look at Johnny Carson you look
back then they either missed the show
that came out of had some comments but
they made sure to get back to jokes that
is your job to try and entertain people
just I hate talking about this oh you
don't know you don't you did this with
Cecil the lion haha you Chuck Schumer
right the portion of your monologue so
that you could between throwing your
actual physical child at politicians for
political gain on healthcare you had
some talking points because chuck
schumer gave them to you
it's really and what other job can you
do this to me Kimmel I'm sure I'm
supposed to be a trashman but yeah it's
just so difficult lately well you know
I'm a cardiac surgeon but I just you
know I'm just I'm just not it's just
going too hard to do it if you think
it's impossible to do your job Jimmy
Kimmel quit it's not the job for you and
this is the issues when people go on
their Jimmy Kimmel was not given this
and this is when people you know there
was that documentary shut up and sing
yeah I'm the Dixie Chicks like they just
want us to shut up and sing yeah we do
here's what doesn't mean you have to
shut up and sing at a dinner party
doesn't you have to shut up and sing in
your own living room does it mean that
people telling Jimmy Kimmel they're not
with telling you can't have political
opinions to yourself but you weren't
given that platform the platform of this
late-night show because of your
political views you were given the
platform in order to create comedy your
job is to create comedy and in these
scenarios it's more important than ever
your job is more important than on days
where it's easy to do on days where it's
hard people want to go home they want to
relax they want to laugh that's what we
try to do with this show people now can
no longer turn to the NFL well did they
used to tune into the NFL because they
wanted to hear their political
strategists on the o-line not exactly
and they didn't want Jimmy Kimmel or
Conan O'Brien Jay Leno take your pick
some they didn't want these people to be
in these positions because we valued
their political commentary these people
are late night hosts Jimmy Kimmel and
here's the thing you're pretty funny guy
but you are so woeful II under equipped
to provide any political commentary
whatsoever that's probably why you need
Chuck Schumer to do it for you people
are turning on you your numbers are
terrible people want you to do your job
like the rest of us have to do our job
because when you don't and you're
arguing from an intellect or a litany of
intellectual fallacies it gets kind of
contrast we talked about this people
like ben shapiro people like thomas soul
you look at Milton Freeman there's an
argument from truth we need to provide
as much information as humanly possible
and let the cards fall where they may
with Jimmy Kimmel all of his arguments
are predicated on you not knowing
anything about firearms and so all I ask
you is run a quick Google search on any
one of these talking points and tell me
if you think I'm wrong
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button it's a circular
button now that says subscribe if not
head on over the Young Turks that's
probably more your speed
although they're coming over at Cinque
we know you're here watching I can smell
you from here there's also a recommended
video box playing right up there you can
join the monk little otter with
credit.com slash mug Club for daily
content so we're not dependent here on
YouTube shank no go you don't need to
stay here this isn't good for it's bad
for your soul